[Music]
hello everyone
so uh we'll continue our discussion of
the kinematics chapter
and we'll be starting
today with the all important
section on strain now you're all
familiar with
the concept of strain having studied it
since your
plus two as well as in your first year
uh what we are going to do here is to
build
on those initial concepts those those
fundamental
concepts where we define strain to be
the ratio between the difference between
the final length
and the initial length with
the ratio with the initial length so
based on that fundamental definition but
posed within the framework that we have
been developing till now
in this kinematics chapter will be able
to generalize
particularly the two-dimensional
concepts of strain that you have
been studying in your first year so the
plan is this
build on the fundamental definitions
that you have learned since your plus
two
but within the current framework and
then to generalize the concepts of
strain
that you have studied in your first year
so
uh first of all what we do is to define
something called the engineering strain
the definition of engineering stream
as i just mentioned we are going to
build on the
absolutely fundamental definition that
strain is nothing but the
ratio of two difference lengths uh first
the numerator being the
difference between the final length and
the initial length and the numerator
being
the initial length so
the engineering strain will be depicted
by this symbol uh epsilon e
[Music]
this is our symbol for engineering
string
and just as we had used
this particular symbol or definition
earlier in the context of
the displacement vector uh we'll again
use it here so this stands
for uh the definition the colon in front
of the equal to sign
and within the context of our current
mathematical framework
we are going to say that in the
numerator we have the difference between
the
final length and the initial length in
this form
so
the absolute value of the d small x
vector it depicts the final length
of the lens segment under consideration
which is basically if you go back to our
previous diagrams
you can see that the d
small x vector is nothing but
this line segment p dash q dash
and the d capital expected is nothing
but
this eq
so that goes in the numerator and in the
denominator
we have this the capital x vector
okay so and this is the
uh the raw definition of the engineering
string
but there is a little bit of a problem
if we have to actually
obtain a useful expression from this
because you see
this definition it involves the absolute
values or the magnitudes
of the of the two vectors the small x
vector and the d capital x vector
now because these are the magnitudes of
vector quantities
so their mathematical representation
would definitely
involve some sort of the square root now
dealing with square roots is not very
convenient
so what we are going to do is instead of
the magnitudes themselves
we are going to instead const consider
the
squares of the magnitudes and that will
make our life a little bit
easier so
[Music]
we consider the squares of the
magnitudes
now
the small x vector magnitude
where you can immediately see that this
is nothing but
the dot product of the dx vector
with itself similarly
the square of the magnitude of the
capital x vector
is nothing but the capital expected
dotted with
itself
all right so in order to obtain
some kind of a nice expression involving
this
engineering string what we'll do is
we'll begin
our mathematical manipulations starting
from this one
the square of the magnitude of the d
small
x vector so if we do that
what we are going to obtain is
something along this line
that
dx vector magnitude square
is equal to
[Music]
this thing
and this is equal to
[Music]
you see this is what i'm using here
is i'm going back
and looking at
these expressions so the small x1
is equal to this big thing involving the
derivatives of u1 similarly i'll be
using
the dx2 here in the dx3
from here so basically what i'm doing
here is
uh writing so maybe this will be cleared
if i write this as
dx1 where
plus d x 2
square plus d
x 3 square and what i have written till
now
uh here this is just the d
small x1 square so
i have to write the small x2 square
and that will be this
again a square over this so this is just
the d
x two squared from here and finally for
the d
one x three square what we have is the
capital x3
plus this entire term involving the
derivatives of
u3 this time
you can square over this so this is a
rather long expression
now it may seem like not a very good
idea to expand this
but and we're not going to do that
explicitly over this
lecture but it will be useful to write
down
a somewhat compacted answer to this
so we are going to do that in our next
slide so
the plan is like this that we are going
to expand all this out
not explicitly but we are going to do
that and collect the various
terms so uh even before expanding you
can imagine that
we will definitely obtain d capital x 1
square from here
d capital x 2 square from here and the
capital x 3 square from here
and those three things together
that will be just this d capital uh
expected magnitude square so
uh that's good and
the other terms also will end up
giving us some sort of a nice symmetric
expression so without further ado let us
actually write down
uh that expression in a nice compact
representation
so
we are again going to write this thing
but in a compact notation
this is
as i had told you
i'm going to get these first of all
but
they together
[Music]
mean just this in addition
i will obtain
a number of other terms which i collect
and represent in this fashion
i'm going to use another set of symbols
to
reduce the length of the expression here
so this is capital e11
i'm going to write down the expressions
for e11
etc down below
plus some terms involving the
process the crosses between the x1 x2
x2 x3 and x3 x1
so written in this form it gives us some
idea of the nice symmetricity of the
situation
of course you understand that the the
actual expressions of this
e11 e2 to e33 e1 to e23
which is here and sorry
i need to write that d x3 here
then comes the e23 and the
e31 will come with this t
x three d x one so all these expressions
uh of the of the e's
they will be quite long but
written in this form uh it is it is
relatively compact
okay so now comes the big part
where
p11 is equal to
[Music]
this should be uh tell you to
h222 is similarly l
u2 del x2
plus
and q1 again but this time
the derivative with respect to x2
[Music]
again i emphasize that it is not by some
magic shortcut that i am obtaining these
expressions
we have to actually expand
this big thing here this all these
square terms here
and obtain these expressions
but in the interest of time i'm not
going through all those detailed steps
this time we take the derivatives with
respect to x3
take the squares just as before
okay now we have the cross terms
that you want to
so this is going to be interesting
so you see
we have
u1 del x2 here plus
del u2 del x1
plus
you please note that
this this term it does not involve any
second
order derivative rather it is the
multiplication of two first order
derivatives
proceeding further we have
[Music]
similarly for e 2 3
we have the cross between 2 and 3 so del
u 2
del x 3 plus del u 3
del x 2 and the rest of the terms can be
easily written down as before
and finally for e31 we have
del q3 and x1 let's
del u1 del x3
plus the rest of the terms as before
please note that in each of these terms
these
these these are the non-linear terms or
the quadratic terms
each of these they involve the u1 u2 and
u3
but it is in the denominator uh the
partial derivatives
here we have the x 1 x 2 combination
uniformly
all over the terms
corresponding to this 1 2 here similarly
when there is 2
3 here we have del x 2 del x 3 in the
denominator in each of these terms
similarly when we have e three one here
corresponding to the three and one
index we have del x three del x one del
x three del x one
and del x three del x one here okay so
overall uh it is important to note that
the the entire expression has been
considerably simplified by
writing these in terms of the various
components of this
e11 okay now
uh
so i think i missed a term here so
it should be 2 here there should be a 2
here
and there should be a 2 here so
this is something i wanted to mention
while i was writing this
e1 to e23 and e31 uh you see
although we have written these three
terms we have not explicitly written
down
anything for e21 e32 and e 1 3
but you note from these expressions that
had we written the e 2 1
this would have been exactly this term
just the order in which these various
terms have been written
they would have been reversed but that
would not make any difference
similarly for e32 it would have been
exactly this expression just with the
order of the terms reversed uh and
similarly for e13
and because we we do not write those
terms explicitly
but they are actually present so
because you understand that they
originate
from squaring these various terms here
on the previous slide
so because we are not explicitly writing
the contribution from e21 so you write a
2 in front of this with the
understanding that
this e 1 2 solely captures the
responsibility of
the e to 1 expression also similarly
this 2
there is that responsibility for e32 and
this to carry the responsibility for
e13 all right
so in the in the next part of the
lecture
we are going to see how
now this expression for the d small x
magnitude square can be utilized to
obtain some very useful
expressions thank you